so in terms of inherently interpretable
models we started our discussion about
you know things like shallow trees or
like simple linear models or simple
rule-based models and so on uh in this
module for the next 40 minutes or so
we'll do a quick overview of some of
these approaches so let me start by
saying that I am not going to touch on
the very basic sort of linear models or
regularized linear models with like L1
or l0 or L2 style regressions
regularized regressions but instead I'm
going to start from something like
around the year 2014 2015 uh since when
since then there has been more renewed
interest in you know sort of like
building inherently interpretable models
exploring newer ways than what we had
with respect to you know previous work
in 70s and 80s right so what I'm not
covering is few things so just linear
models linear logistic regression
regularizations on top of them and then
decision reconstruction using greedy
approaches so those are the things that
I'm going to sort of put a pin on and
assume some familiarity for all of you
but I'll start from the year 2015 and go
over some of the approaches that came
since then okay does that sound good
all right okay so uh again as I was
saying so with the renewed interest
recently a lot of approaches again the
constructs is probably what I would
encourage all of you to take away from
some of these discussions so the people
have tried to build several kinds of
inherently interpretable models so one
is rule-based models the other is risk
scores and I'll explain what they are in
a little bit and then there is
generalized relative models which had
gained a lot of popularity recently and
then there are prototype based models
okay so let's go over each of these oh
and also attention-based models all
right
Okay so let's go to the first set of
approaches that is the rule-based
approaches uh and you know I'm going to
first talk about a couple of approaches
in this categories before I move on to
another one uh this approach called
Bayesian ruleless was introduced in 2016
uh by Ben Latham and Cynthia Rudin and
this was basically an approach that is I
mean the output of this approach looks
something like this right so it's a
sequence of if else if rules and this is
actually the output that they get with
their method uh as a classifier for
stroke prediction right so this is
basically like they were working with
some doctors and Healthcare experts to
design models that can be used to
predict Strokes in advance or stroke
risk in at once and the requirement in
those settings is that doctors want to
precisely see the rules that can be used
to sort of employ as they go you know in
their day-to-day decision making right
so they didn't want any kind of complex
models they wanted something as simple
as this but also they wanted something
accurate right so this approach is kind
of motivated by that scenario
uh so what exactly is their approach
right so their approach is basically
proposing a generative model uh which is
designed to produce these kinds of if
else if lists and the way they Design
This generative model is by striking a
balance between accuracy
interpretability and computation and
I'll go into some more details about
this approach but you know you could
look at or anyone could look at that
particular offensive list that we saw
and say wait why are they just not using
other similar models for example what
about decision trees like cards c5.0 C
4.5 why are they not using these kinds
of models right the reason or at least
what the paper argues is that these
kinds of models employ greedy based
approaches so while greedy methods as we
all know are efficient they can often
get stuck in local Minima right so the
argument that this paper makes is that
it is is computationally great but you
know the resulting solution is not going
to be perfect in terms of accuracy or
interpretability
so that's why they sort of like put
forth that there is a need for new
methods to even generate things like
rulers from scratch
okay
so for those of you who are familiar
with Bayesian models here is what their
generative model or their generative
process looks like if you think about it
and for those of you who are not
familiar there's no need to worry too
much all that goes on in generative
models or these kinds of Bayesian topic
modeling style approaches is that you
sort of assume a particular process that
generates the data and then you have a
bunch of unknown parameters as you
assume this process and then you work
backwards and then try to estimate or
learn those unknown parameters using
different techniques right so that's the
basic you know Intuition or concept
behind generative models so what is this
particular generative model trying to do
so essentially the generation process
says you know first of all pick a list
length so how many rules are there in
the list you know we sample that number
and then we basically sample a default
rule which will apply for 3 things that
no other rule is going to apply for and
then we are going to sample the M
different other rules in our offensive
set of the list and for each rule what
we do we basically sample the
cardinality of the antecedent which is
the left hand side of the rule how many
predicates are in the left hand side of
the rule and then we basically sample
the predicates on the left hand side of
the rule right so you sample the number
and then you sample the predicates and
then of course you sample what should be
on the right hand side of the rule right
and then for then the observations will
be generated from these sampled rules as
you know find find the rule that
actually applies to this instance in the
data and then if no antecedents apply or
no rules apply then you basically give
it the default rule otherwise you sort
of sample a class label based on that
rule that applies to this instance right
so that's the high level if we were to
sort of think about constructing these
rules that's intuitively how you would
think about this kind of a process okay
so I want to note few things here so one
is the the sort of sampling the
predicates or the conditions and when I
use the word predicate I basically just
mean you know these conditions are the
predicates right so it's like if
transient is basic or if transient uh
ismic attack that's the condition or
that's the predicate
all right
so a here is the set of pre-mind
antecedents so what do I mean by that is
whenever they are trying to sort of pick
the left hand side of the rules they're
actually selecting from a set of
candidate left hand sides that are
already available okay so they use some
sort of like frequent items at mining
for those of you who are familiar with a
prairie style algorithms so they kind of
use that to sort of determine what are
some of the frequently occurring
patterns in the data and then try to
pick left hand sides from those okay so
there is a candidate set and they try to
pick from it so now just at a very high
level for this kind of a generative
process we use something called as
Metropolis Hastings algorithm it's
essentially like for those of you who
are familiar with mcmc or Gib sampling
method so this is essentially one of
those classes of algorithms and using
this they go back and estimate all the
parameters in that generative process
that they don't know right so for
example before constructing the list you
don't know what will be the cardinality
of the antecedent or the number of
predicates of antecedent of some rules
or you don't know how many rules you're
picking right so but using this process
they go back and you know sort of learn
those and then build the list yes that's
the high level idea
all right so one of the major uh sources
of practical feasibility here is the set
of pre-minded antecedents or pre-bind
left-hand sides of these rules
and that basically helps them reduce the
model space because you are essentially
searching over those rules only in order
to find your final list right so if your
candidate rule set is small then you
basically have smaller search space to
look at right so they can control the
complexity of the problem through that
right and as long as this set of
pre-minded antecedent list is expressive
you will be able to find an accurate
enough decision list uh plus you know
having that said to be small can also
help with like better generalization as
well right so you need to choose that
set carefully in order to find a good or
an accurate decision list with this
method
okay any thoughts questions
all right okay
so the next approach which kind of tries
to simplify this process a bit more
further and also makes it more efficient
uh and also adds some tweaks on
interpretability which I'll also discuss
a bit more in our analysis section is
interpretable decision sets and you know
this is like an example decision set
classifier for disease diagnosis task on
a particular data set right so what
immediately kind of strikes to you is
instead of if else if rules there is a
set of unordered if then rules here so
that's the main difference in terms of
how the rules look like you would be
surprised to know that even just a
change in the construct from if else if
to if then already changes significantly
how people perform certain tasks for
example and I'm going to talk about this
lot more in our analysis section to show
how even simple changes in how an
interpretation looks right can have big
differences in terms of like you know
let's say if a doctor is looking at
these rules and trying to make some
decisions and so on the cognitive load
that is incurred with small changes can
actually be pretty big right so while
computationally we might be like oh
that's a list you know there is ordering
there's a set there's no ordering like
that's the difference but like these
things have a lot of impact and we'll
talk about that a bit more later
so this approach will also hopefully
make it clear to you as to what exactly
is the deciderator Behind these kinds of
rule approaches that are being used uh
to construct these rule-based models
again in a renewed fashion since 2015.
um so this is what is the set of
criteria that this approach is focusing
on uh which is you want to account for
recall Precision distinctness of the
rules sparsity in the rules and then
covering all the classes right and
recall and precision is important for
accurate predictions and distinctness
parsimony and covering all the classes
is important for interpretability right
so just to go over some of the terms
here and just bear with me as we do this
because these are the building blocks of
a lot of the things that we'll talk
about later so then we are going to just
skim through these details and say oh we
refer to them then okay all right
so the objective function in this case
as we were saying it's trying to sort of
Encompass five different criteria right
so uh parsimony or the sparsity is
basically trying to ensure that there
are fewer rules in the rules set so now
our goal is we have to pick from a
candidate set of rules that we have we
need to pick a subset of some K if then
if then rules and then that will become
our classifier right and the first
Criterion in that is we favor fewer
rules so we want to either
sorry minimize the number of rules which
is denoted by size of r r maximize the
negative of that so that's essentially
what you see is that expression there
okay and also fewer predicates which is
basically the number of conditions in
the rules that should also be smaller so
we want to minimize that or maximize its
sort of complement or it's negative
right now in terms of distinctness
because what we are looking at here is
trying to find a set of if then rules we
want to ensure that the points being
covered by these set of rules is minimal
right or covered by multiple rules in
this set of rules is minimal because
otherwise you are essentially just
creating duplicate rules which you don't
need right so you are trying to
basically minimize two Notions of
overlap which is intra class overlap and
Inter class overlap so basically the
point is that the number of points that
satisfy more than one unrul should be
minimized okay so that's what this
expression is trying to capture and then
the next one is class coverage which is
you are basically checking to see that
there is at least some rule
corresponding to a given class or any
given Class C so that Minority classes
for example in the kinds of data sets we
are looking at like the healthcare data
sets some rare cancers they are like
present in such tiny number of samples
in the data that classifiers might often
just ignore them because it doesn't
matter to their overall accuracy right
but here we are sort of forcing that to
happen and we want every class to be
represented in some Rule and then of
course there is the Precision piece
where you're trying to minimize
incorrect covers right so basically we
want to minimize for each rule that we
pick in this set of rules the number of
points which satisfy the rule but do not
belong to the class that the rule is
assigning the point to right so that
ensures Precision which is in important
for accuracy and then recall and the way
we are sort of trying to enforce recall
is that
you encourage each point to be covered
by at least one rule in the set that you
produce right so for example that
correct cover that you see there that's
basically capturing the number of data
points which satisfy uh s and also which
is the rule is and also belong to the
class C right so you're basically trying
to ensure that no point is left out from
this covering process okay all right so
putting it all together what you see is
you can basically combine these put it
into an optimization problem you know
essentially you'll get some kind of Arc
Max problem like this and then a
summation over all these factors so the
property of this kind of an objective or
the set of properties of this kind of an
objective is that this turns out to be
something that's called a non-normal
non-monitode and submodular optimization
problem okay so without going into too
much details because you know that's not
the point of this conversation uh
maximizing such a problem turns out to
be NP hard but the good news is there
are some approaches which can provide
reasonable approximations and we can use
those to efficiently solve this
objective right in fact faster than what
the Bayesian rule list was trying to do
okay all right
so with that I think we are kind of
pretty much covered like some of the uh
key approaches that were proposed as the
interests in rulers and rules that's got
rejuvenated somewhere around 2015.
um there are also several other classes
of inter interpretable models so next
one is called as risk scores uh so risk
scores are basically things that look
like this so I'm going to just let you
guys see this as a pause for a minute
okay
so what you see here in these kinds of
risk score lists is that for each
condition you are assigning points for
example if the number of Prior errors is
greater than or equal to two that's
worth one point right and you know if
your age it release is greater than or
equal to 40 that's actually a negative
one point so you're trying to sort of
create this kind of scores associated
with conditions and at the end of the
day you will just sum up all those
scores and the resulting score will tell
you how risky it is for example for a
defendant to be released or how much of
a risk there is in a person defaulting
on a loan and things like that right so
it's almost like saying if this
condition holds add a point and you know
as these conditions hold key padding
points what is the total and the total
will tell you how risky the person is
okay
so this kind of a construct is actually
pretty popular both in medicine and
criminal justice like uh I myself
collaborate with doctors and folks in
criminal justice and they are very
comfortable with this kind of risk
course because all they have to do is
just kind of go through that checklist
and assign points and then they get a
risk right risk score so that's why
they're pretty popular in fact the
existing models of risk scores that are
out there quite a bit in practice in
domains like medicine and criminal
justice are like handwritten or
hand-drawn risk or checklist which have
been sort of made up by domain experts
or doctors or you know lawyers and
judges of course they're using their
domain expertise in coming up with those
lists but essentially they sort of
prefer these kinds of checklists with
scores uh quite a bit so there's
something that naturally comes to them
in terms of utility Okay so how do we
now construct these kinds of risk score
checklists using data right so that's
the problem or that's the question that
was dealt with by Austin and Rudin in
the year 2016. okay so this is roughly
the kind of problem that they formulate
it turns out to be a pretty complicated
problem to actually solve correctly
accurately so we'll get to that a bit
later but essentially if you see what
this is trying to do is that so you're
trying to basically uh formulate or come
up with this kind of set of conditions
and corresponding scores
such that you are basically
minimizing two terms so the first one is
basically
ensuring that your scores work out so
the scores that you are applying and
then you will sort of use those scores
to then convert them into the
probability of risk associated with
someone let's say right so the scoring
mechanism the first term will ensure
that that score scoring mechanism or the
scores you are assigning to each of the
you know the predicates in your risk
score list uh actually map to the uh
precise risk in practice are the real
estimates of the risk in the data so
that's that's what that last term is
doing in the objective and then the
second term you are essentially trying
to sort of minimize the number of the
predicates or the terms that will get on
to this risk score checklist right so
you don't want the checklist to be you
know having like 100 attributes there
right so you want to minimize that so
that's what that second term which is a
regularization term is doing and then of
course there could be a bunch of other
constraints on how you will pick these
uh conditions that you see in the risk
score checklist and also the scores that
you assign to them for example there
might be a condition that don't assign
continuous valued scores the scores that
you assign should be integers because
those are more interpretable right so
you can think of them as 1.2 point but
not as 1.73 or something right so uh
there could be a bunch of such
constraints both on what features you're
picking and also what scores you are
assigning to them that is encoded by the
condition there right so the above when
we put together some of the more sort of
practical conditions into this problem
setup uh turns out to be a mixed integer
program and it is optimized in this
particular work using a cutting plane
method and a branch and mount technique
so it does not have an easy solution but
I think we'll leave it at that okay
all right so the next class of models is
the generalized additive models
um and
okay so this is the class of models
which basically produces outputs like
this so what you are essentially seeing
is that you kind of see what are called
as shape functions associated with input
variables so what this is showing is
demand is your outcome variable okay and
each of the variables you see on the
x-axis are your input features so this
is kind of showing how the outcome
variable will change as a function of
each of the input variables right so as
R increases what happens to demand and
as you know temperature increases what
happens to demand and so on and by the
way these are not just plots from the
data this is actually the output of the
method that is generalized relative
models okay so it shows you how the
output can be modeled as different
functions of input variables so the
output in this case is essentially a
summation of all the curves that you're
seeing here
okay it's like an additive combination
so just to show you a precise
mathematical form of this uh
so for example the first row here is
essentially like a linear regression
model right so your Y is basically this
kind of a additive or like a linear
combination of different features that
you have and then we go one step up to a
generalized linear model uh where you
can take a function of Y and then model
it as a linear combination of different
input features right then we can think
of an editor model where your y will
just be an additive combination but of
different input of different functions
of the input variable right so each
input variable you can learn a separate
function over it and then the additive
combination of that will give you y now
a generalized version of that is
basically a generalized additive model
where you can take a function of the
output variable that is g of Y and then
think of that or consider that to be
this kind of an additive combination of
you know input functions functions of in
different input variables okay and of
course if you want to make the model
more complex you know your Y is
basically just a function of all the
input variables and that could be an
arbitrarily complex function right so
think of deep neural Nets and so on
which fall into the last category so the
stable also kind of tries to summarize
some of the knowledge that we have been
thinking about so if you think of a
linear model it's just a bunch of
coefficients associated with each
feature we multiply the feature where
the coefficient add everything up we get
the output right so the interpretability
or the intelligibility factor is high
accuracy may not always be high of
course depending on the data it might
but it may not be as high now if you
think of the generalized linear model
which is something like a logistic
regression in that case also your
intelligibility or ability to see five
weights and then see what they're doing
that is good but again accuracy may not
always be good right and then the third
row is the additive model where you are
just thinking of additive combination of
different functions your intelligibility
is probably a bit worse off than just
seeing you know the actual variable
itself because now we are seeing a
function function your accuracy might
improve a bit though right and the same
is the case with generalized relative
model so you are seeing complex
functions now so your interpretability
is probably not as high as just thinking
of it as one variable and its weight but
at the same time it helps with accuracy
a bit right okay
so uh Gams and Gams squares I guess
that's how they're called so these have
again become popular starting 2015 2016.
so Gams are essentially what we just saw
so they sort of model these first order
terms and their like additive
combinations of the functions of the
different input variables gam square is
basically going one step further and it
is also considering pairwise
interactions between features right so
the claim is that these kinds of shape
functions that you saw earlier that are
produced by these approaches are
interpretable and we'll talk about that
as well in just a bit right so how to
learn these kinds of models so the idea
here is that given that you're trying to
fit a function on each input variable
and then do an additive combination of
it so you basically represent each
feature or each component as a spline
and then you basically use a least
squares formulas and then run an
optimization procedure to sort of
balance smoothness of the spline as well
as the empirical error right so that's
that's how you go about it and then with
gam Square you also have the higher
order interaction terms to consider so
in this case you first build a gam which
is without the interaction term take the
residual error okay and then rank all
possible pairs of interactions uh in the
reset dual and basically try to pick
some top K interaction pairs that are
contributing to the residual using some
sort of feature selection type
approaches and then uh like even cross
validation right and then just pick
those top K Pairs and now try to again
repeat this learning procedure where
you're basically representing each the
pairwise interaction term as a spline
and you're just sort of using a least
squares formulation to fit it okay so
yeah if some of this feels a bit for
fuzzy that's fine these are details of
how exactly people are trying to learn
such models but the important piece is
the construct that you saw which
basically looks something like this and
you know the claim is these kinds of
things are actually interpretable
um I think I'll just uh sort of do a
poll here to see how many of you think
this is interpretable
show off hands
okay that is some of you all right uh
what about the rest
how many of you think it's not
interpretable let me see if there are
people who are undecided oh there are
some undecided folks okay uh so why do
you think it's not interpretable
I think maybe there are one or two
features
right and what do you feel about
thinking about this as the whole outcome
variable is some kind of additive
combination of all these shapes
right so I think I understand the
sensitivities of each variable but not
the combined effect of materials across
multiplication right so I think the the
sort of intelligibility or the
interpretability I know we are using
these terms and what Loosely but of Gams
has been debated quite a bit uh so again
there are pieces of it that make it
interpretable which is you can kind of
see how the output would vary as a
function of individual input variables
right but at the same time thinking
about all the variables in one shot or
in conjunction and then thinking what
their effect would be on the output is a
little hard to Fathom from something
like this right so there have been
debates about like whether this should
be considered interpretable or not in
fact I think you know there is a death
of like doing more user studies to
actually check if some of this is
considered interpretable if so by what
kinds of users and so on okay
all right
so with that I'm going to keep us moving
and let's talk a little bit about
prototype based models okay so first
from here on we are actually also
jumping into some more complex aspects
but I'm first going to describe a very
simple approach for what would be a
prototype based models and then we'll
see how to sort of make deep learning
models interpretable by incorporating
you know prototypes or some other
constructs okay all right
okay
so the goal with this particular like
the basic problem we are considering
here is to identify K prototypes or
instances from a given data set
such that if there is a new instance we
can use these prototypes to assign
labels for that instance right so you
want to pick some representative points
in the data set such that if you give me
a new data point I should be able to
compute the nearest neighbors among
these representative points and assign
the label of that nearest neighbor and
that should be the correct label for
that new data point so in some sense I'm
trying to build a classifier through
these representative data points okay is
that clear right
so the way to sort of the way at least
this paper goes about this problem is
that you consider each instance to cover
some Epsilon neighborhood around it
right like an Epsilon ball around it we
consider that each instance sort of
covers that neighborhood okay which
means and cover means if a point lies
within that Epsilon distance from the uh
From Any Given instance then you say
this point belongs to the Epsilon
neighborhood of that instance and I'll
show you pictorially in just a little
bit right so once you associate this
kind of a neighborhood with each
instance now what you have done is you
can sort of see the analogy between this
and a rule right so earlier we were
trying to come up with a subset of rules
in the rule set that we discussed about
or the interpretable decision sets that
we discussed about we were coming up
with a subset of rules that can cover
all the points in the data and also be
accurate classifiers right so similarly
we are just replacing the construct of
the rule now with a prototype or an
instance and an instance is set to cover
all the points within the Epsilon ball
neighborhood around that instance right
so for example and then once we see this
sort of deduction or reduction to this
problem we thought about earlier as soon
as you define this neighborhood you can
apply all the optimization problem that
we talked about earlier in the context
of rule sets and then find a subset of
prototypes that maximally cover the data
but is also accurately assigning labels
to the points that are getting covered
right so just to show some pictorial
representation of this and the value of
this Epsilon that defines the
neighborhood can be given by an end user
right so this is basically showing for
different values of Epsilon if if we
pick certain prototypes what are the
neighborhoods that they're covering
right so if Epsilon is small you will
end up picking a lot of prototypes
because you know it's only covering a
small portion of the data each prototype
is only covering a small portion of the
data but as you increase the value of
Epsilon you will end up picking fewer
prototypes because each prototype covers
a larger chunk of the data right and
then so essentially what you have built
is some kind of a nearest neighbor
classifier and you have sort of took
some prototypes out for building such a
classifier
all right so this is another popular
class and this kind of nicely feeds into
a discussion on so so far we have been
talking about you know we want simpler
models simpler constructs how do I learn
rule lists and Rule sets and you know
Gams and you know simple prototype based
models so I'm sure some of you are
wondering okay when will we get a deep
learning right so the all these seem
like nice and simple models but these
are not going to help with my accuracy I
want to run deep learning models so what
about interpretability there right so
here we are jumping into that territory
foreign
okay so this is basically and there are
few approaches which try to do something
like this the idea here is that you can
make deep learning architectures
interpretable by essentially introducing
these kinds of layers right so there's a
prototype layer followed by a fully
connected layer so you can augment these
two layers almost towards the end of a
given neural network architecture and
try to get some interpretability uh in
terms of the predictions being made okay
so this particular the specific
architecture that you're seeing what it
has is this first part is basically what
is like a auto encoder right and then
you take the output of the encoder and
then you pass it to the Prototype layer
and the fully connected layer and then
you get the output and we'll go into the
details of what each layer is doing okay
so
uh yeah so like let's say our input has
a dimensionality of you know P right so
it's all real numbers so there's the
vector uh of real numbers and of
Dimension B and then that passes through
the encoder and then it gets transformed
into you know RQ which is basically a q
dimensional Vector of real numbers and
you know Q is typically less than P
right so for those of you who are
wondering what exactly this component is
think of it as essentially it's creating
a low dimensional representation of your
input right so in some sense you are
trying to reduce the dimensions in your
data while preserving the most important
information okay so you're doing that in
the first component and then you are
inputting a q dimensional Vector of real
numbers to the Prototype layer and what
is the Prototype layer doing the
Prototype layer is actually responsible
for computing or learning the Prototype
types and more specifically each node in
the Prototype layer is Computing this
value right so for example P1 is
Computing so given an input data point x
we got this Z which is the transformed
version of X and then each of those
nodes in the Prototype layer is
Computing the sort of this L2 Norm
difference or you know you can think of
it as the distance between Z and P1 okay
so between the transformed input point
and the Prototype that it's learning or
it is currently learned right so in some
sense each layer is just outputting the
distance between the input point or some
transformation of it and then the
Prototype chosen so far okay
all right so now that that's the case
the dimensionality of that Vector will
be M so that is basically you get one
distance value with respect to each
prototype
right so you get you know first node is
Computing the distance between Z and P1
second node is Computing the distance
between Z and P2 and so on you get one
scalar value from each of those nodes so
the entire output of that layer will be
M different values
okay
all right so then the fully connected
layer is essentially Computing awaited
some of these distances right so you got
the distances now you can make these
distances the combin the weighted
combination of these distances using the
uh this fully connected layer here
and then of course so that will sort of
take the dimensionality from RM and
you're sort of multiplying that before
with w and so basically that will end up
being a k dimensional vector and that in
turn can be passed on to the soft Max
layer in order to Output probabilities
over K classes right so basically what
you're doing in sort of all these
details is that you're essentially
trying to so normally deep neural
networks would basically have let's say
this component
none of these two layers and then you go
straight there right but you're
introducing a couple of interpretability
layers there are mainly the Prototype
layer there so that for every instance
you also have a prototype that sort of
says something like oh I made this
prediction on this instance because it
looks like this prototype
does that make sense so that's the thing
that we are trying to get to uh here by
adding these kinds of layers
okay
right
Okay so
I think we have a little bit more time
before the break and I'm going to cover
this as well so the last is
attention-based models again this has
gained a lot of popularity in recent
times
so the idea is just like we were
thinking about adding these prototype
layers uh to deep neural network
architectures here we are thinking of
adding another kind of layer which is
called as attention layer right okay
so just to illustrate this
let me first show you this example of a
machine translation task okay so there
is nothing uh interpretable here we have
not yet introduced anything but this is
an example of an architecture of a
models that people use to do machine
translation okay so the idea here is
that so there is your input you are
trying to translate this sentence from
English to French okay so there are
three tokens in your input and each
token is passed through an encoder which
will basically generate some kind of a
hidden state representation for that
token
okay so that's what this side is doing
all right and as you can see the hidden
state representation for the second
token depends on that as well as you
know this input right so both are the
inputs here so in some sense you are
trying to basically take each word and
then get some Vector representation of
that word through some process like just
think of it in that abstract way okay
so now once this encoder is sort of
built uh the next part is that there is
a decoder on the other side which is
basically so there is a context Vector
in between I think for the purpose of
this architecture you could assume that
c is basically just uh taking the value
of H3 which is the encoded
representation of the last word there
okay so I think there are architectures
which do use that and some functions of
H3 and so on but let's just assume C is
H3 okay and C is often referred to as
the context Vector because it is trying
to capture some context about the input
okay all right so now the next set of
layers that you have is the decoder and
that takes c as input and then tries to
generate a hidden state representation
for each of the output words and then
you know once you generate that hidden
straight presentation for say the first
word in the output then conditioned on
that hidden state representation you can
generate the actual word right so that's
how machine translation happens with
models like these
okay
so now
uh attention layers how to add it in
this kind of an architecture right so
before I describe exactly what is
attention here the change that you
hopefully notice from the previous slide
to this one is that we kind of added
some complexity to the context Vector
right so what we are doing is now the
encoder has remained the same the
decoder has remained the same the
context Vector is no longer just C so we
now have like separate context vectors
corresponding to each token of the
output right so the way we introduce
interpretability into this is as follows
so the context Vector corresponding to
each hidden representation of an output
token uh which is Si is basically the
hidden representation of the output
token I so the context Vector will be
modeled as this kind of a combination
which is a i j and then h j right so in
some sense what you are doing is you're
representing each context Vector as some
kind of a combination of each of the
Hidden representations from the encoder
side so you're no longer saying I am
just going to take H3 and then all the
decoder pieces will depend on just H3
what you're saying is my context will be
some combination of these three and I
will learn what that combination is and
that combination will tell me the
importance of each of the input words in
generating each of the output words
right so that's exactly what you're
doing when you basically add this kind
of a term there
okay
so in some sense the AIG that we have
introduced there it captures the
attention placed on input token J when
determining the decoder hidden State SI
right so in some sense how much does the
output word I depend on each of the
input words J that's what is captured by
a i j right and that is basically the
notion of attention weights and that
basically describes the importance of
each of the input features in these
kinds of Networks